Hi guys, good evening. Am I audible?
Okay, thank you. Let's wait a little. There are very few people here.
If you have any questions, you can ask.
First live class sir. Nice.
But I don't know why the rest of the people are not coming.
Any other questions?
We are waiting for a minute or two more. After that we will start the class.
If in case anyone has any questions, you can ask.
Good evening sir. I want to know the source for studying maths.
Shivani, I would recommend that you study the maths part in our DSMP course.
It would be nice for a beginner.
We have covered everything that you need in data science and covered it in a very simple way.
If you are a beginner, you will understand things very easily.
There are multiple sources for linear algebra.
You have a playlist of 3 blue and 1 brown.
There are good resources for optimization.
There are many videos on YouTube for statistics.
There are many videos on YouTube for probability.
If you have a good advanced level maths for understanding research paper.
Still you have seen our whole maths playlist.
Some of my courses on the dashboard are logged.
This should not happen. Ideally all the courses will be unlocked.
You can take a screenshot and drop a mail on support-at-the-rate-campus-x.in.
Many people have come. Let's start the session.
I am sharing the screen. Tell me if you can see my screen.
Can you see my screen?
You can see the one note screen.
Can you see this black screen?
This is our third and fourth session in this course.
Let me give you a quick recap of what we have covered so far.
Then I will tell you the agenda of today's session.
Today's session is interesting. You will learn something new.
By the end of the session, you will learn something good.
So far, we have covered five things in the course LLMEvalse.
First, we covered why do we need evals.
Then we saw what exactly are evals.
We studied model-based and application-based types.
Then we studied how does LLMEvalse look like.
Basically, we discussed an eval pipeline.
Then in the last session, we discussed an interesting topic.
Why do we need multiple eval pipelines for a single application?
I told you that no LLMEvalse-based application is like this where you just put one eval pipeline.
Ideally, what you do is you create multiple eval pipelines for a single application.
I gave you two reasons behind this.
First, I told you that because there are multiple failure points.
We talked about the failure at the component level, at the workflow level, and at the application level.
That is why we have to put evals to monitor all three.
Second, we discussed that there are different risk categories.
We discussed three categories here.
Quality, Safety, and in the last, Operations.
Basically, evals are different for Latency and all types of metrics.
In the last video, we discussed what are the different eval methods through which we perform evaluations.
We discussed three things in this video.
Programmatic methods, LLMEvalse-based as a judge, and how to perform eval with humans.
In nutshell, this is the summary of whatever we have covered in this course till now.
In today's video, we are going to discuss a very important topic.
The topic is Offline Eval vs Online Eval.
First, I will tell you what is offline eval, then I will tell you what is online eval, and then what are the differences between them.
We will see that and you will learn a lot in this process.
This is our agenda for today.
This is the topic that we are going to cover today.
Is it clear till now?
What have we studied till now and what are we going to study today?
Is the agenda clear?
Write Y for yes so that we are on the same page.
Easy, right?
If you are attending all the classes, then you must be understanding what we are doing.
Let's first discuss what offline evals are.
The good thing is that you don't have to read anything new here.
You have already read offline evals.
All the examples that we have discussed till now in the last 2-3 sessions where I have made an eval pipeline for you,
all those eval pipelines are an example of offline eval.
Basically, the foundation of offline eval is that if you apply any eval pipeline on your LLM application before deploying it,
then we call it offline eval.
You might remember that in the last video, we discussed an UPSC application where we made an LLM application
which evaluates the Mock Test of the mains paper like a human.
We discussed step by step how we will do this evaluation.
We made a golden dataset, we used the LLM as a judge method and we performed the evaluation.
Now, this evaluation is taking place after the creation of the software but before deployment.
Which means that this is an example of an offline eval.
In simple words, whenever you have an LLM based application and you want to test it before deploying it,
whether it is worth deploying or not, then we call the evals that you run there as offline eval.
As simple as that.
So, everything that you have read till now, everything comes under offline eval.
So, we didn't learn anything new.
We gave a new name to what we had learned in the past.
So, quickly tell me in the chat that if someone asks you tomorrow what offline evals are,
would you be able to answer?
Can you explain offline eval?
Okay. Easy, right?
Now, let's discuss an important aspect of offline eval.
I want to hear from you.
You tell me what is the main purpose of offline eval?
If there is more than one purpose, then what is it?
Type it once and tell me.
What are the main purposes of an offline eval?
Why do we need an offline eval?
Why don't we make an LLM based software and deploy it directly?
What is the problem?
You have to tell me this.
Actually, it's a very simple question.
One very straightforward answer is that if we deploy it without testing,
then how will the software behave in the production?
We don't know.
And anything can be risky.
I had told you about two or three case studies in the beginning.
Air Canada, Chart GPT.
So, you remember, right?
You cannot deploy an LLM based software into production without testing it.
The first benefit of offline eval is that it gives us a feature of pre-release testing.
Before releasing, I can properly test my eval.
Now, let me tell you an interesting thing.
You will probably read this in the course of LLM Ops.
That the whole process of making the software, testing it and deploying it,
is automated at such a level that you can simply create a gate.
If the result of my eval is above 95%, then deploy my software.
Basically, you are using CI, CD.
And if it is less than 95%, then don't deploy it.
So, in the future, you will read that the testing, the whole eval run,
testing of your software, is also automated.
You make some changes in the software.
As soon as you make changes, your code is pushed on GitHub.
On GitHub, CI is triggered through GitHub actions.
And there is your eval script.
It runs.
You get a score from it.
If the score is above the threshold, then automatically the deployment pipeline is triggered.
If your threshold is below, then you get a notification that the eval test has failed.
So, not only you are getting pre-release testing, but if you use it properly,
then it works like a release gate.
If the eval is properly deployed, if it is not, then it will roll back to the previous version.
So, this is the first benefit.
The second important benefit is that you can compare versions with the help of offline eval.
Let's say you have a choice that you want to make your LLM based software,
like UPSC, with the Clot model or with the OpenAI model.
Let's say.
So, how would you compare these two?
The rest is the same.
The code is the same.
The model is different.
I have to evaluate that for my purpose, the OpenAI model will give better results or the Clot model.
So, how can I do this?
It is very simple.
I will make two versions of my software and run the same eval on both versions.
Since the eval is same, the golden data set is same,
then everything is same.
The field is level.
So, now I can easily identify that the Clot is scoring more in comparison to OpenAI,
which means that I will use the Clot.
You can do this for anything.
You can compare different prompts, different models, different re-rankers, different vector databases.
You can also try out comparing different architectures of your software application.
So, if you have a question in your mind that I have more than one possibility, which one should I choose?
Then this choice will tell you your eval by running it on multiple versions of the software.
This is the second benefit.
Third is regression testing.
This is also a very important benefit.
Does anyone know what regression testing is?
Can anyone tell?
Have you ever heard of it?
I have heard it.
It is a very famous term in software.
Anyone, if you can tell me what regression testing is?
I will wait.
No one knows?
Yes, good. Amar was right.
It's test of change.
So, regression testing is basically that suppose one of your versions of the software is already live.
You observed that suppose this is campusX chatbot, through which students are interacting.
Now, we observed that whenever students are talking about refund, our chatbot is answering cold.
I don't know why.
So, we observed this in pattern production.
So, now what we did is we thought of improving this because we always want our chatbot to talk to our students in a good tone.
So, what I did was I went to my system prompt and made some changes.
You have to be very kind and very polite.
You have to answer well.
I wrote such an instruction.
Now, what happened after writing this instruction is that its personality became very soft.
For example, if someone is asking what is the cost of the insider plan?
And suppose the insider plan cost is 19,500.
So, it is very softly saying to impress the other person instead of 19,500.
It's around 19,000 just to make sure that the other person sounds good.
I know I am not giving a very good example.
But I want to tell you that many times you are making a very complex system.
If you want to improve one thing, then the rest of the things go wrong.
If you are going to improve one thing, then the performance of the other thing goes bad.
This is called regression.
So, it is necessary to test this.
Whenever you are improving your software, you have to make sure that the thing that you are improving is already improved.
But at the same time, something else should not get spoiled.
So, your offline eval helps you in this as well.
How? It's very simple.
It's very simple.
You put different types of cases in the golden data set.
You put questions of different types of students.
So, you try to cover all kinds of cases.
There are refund questions as well.
There are pricing questions as well.
There are course curriculum related questions as well.
So, basically you can run eval on every type of question and find out how your results are coming on every type of question.
So, if your success rate was 90% on the first refund, then after changing to prompt, it should be around 90.
It should not go to 80.
If it is going to 80, then it is clear that there is some form of regression.
And you should not make the change that you have done now.
Is this point clear?
The idea is very simple.
Whenever you make a small change anywhere,
change your model in system prompt, change your vector database, change anything,
then nothing else should be wrong.
So, we can test this as well with the help of offline evals.
This is the main point.
So, in nutshell, we discussed what offline evals are.
What we had read till now is called offline evals.
And see three important benefits of it.
First, we get to do testing before release.
Second, we can compare two versions whenever we are in doubt.
And third, whenever we are making any changes in our existing software,
then we can actually test that there should not be any more problems.
These are the three biggest benefits,
because of which offline evals are super important.
Without this, work cannot be done.
So, the discussion till now is it clear?
We are going very slowly, but we are covering ground.
Let me know if you have any problem till now or if you have any question.
Okay.
Now let's move ahead.
Now let's talk about production.
Suppose you have made your LLM based software.
You have run offline eval on it.
All the results have also passed.
Your software has now been deployed.
Now, let's discuss the problems that can come in production.
So, you will face three major problems in production.
Once your software is deployed, you will face three major problems.
The first problem is that you will get to see a lot of unanticipated inputs.
Let's say, there is a chart bot of CampusX.
When we were testing it in offline setup,
we made a golden dataset in which we put 200-500 questions.
Which we think the user can ask.
But we tested our chart bot on these 200-500 questions.
But when we deploy it, we are opening it for the real world.
Which basically means that now the student can ask any type of question.
Maybe he can ask a question for which we have not even tested our software.
It is written here.
It is possible that people may start talking in Hindi and English.
When we trained the model or fine tuned it, we mostly talked in English.
Because we anticipated that we will talk in English.
There will be a lot of ambiguous half questions.
Where the user will not understand what he is trying to ask.
There will be a lot of angry rants where a question will be hidden behind a lot of anger.
Or a lot of adversarial prompt injections will be tried.
That they will try to find an answer from the chart bot which they should not give.
You will have to face a lot of edge cases.
So this is what happens when you finally put your chart bot in production.
What you have shown till now, what you have tested,
You will get to see a much bigger superset than that.
In which your chart bot can face anything.
So this is the first risk.
We are discussing the risks on production.
Second, you may find emergent or systematic failures.
There are many such small failures which you will not see in the offline setup.
They are only visible when you deploy your software.
What kind of things I am talking about.
Such problems which are only faced on scale.
For example, suddenly a lot of people have come.
We have launched a new course on CampusX.
Suddenly a lot of people have come.
And together in our chart bot, there are thousands of concurrent users.
So suddenly our latency has increased.
Now we could never test this in offline because we cannot bring thousands of users in offline.
So this is a scenario which you can only face in production.
Then if I give you a couple of more examples,
This is a good example.
A subtle bias that only becomes visible across thousands of conversations.
Now it is possible that our model, our chart bot is a little biased against individuals
who come from non-technical backgrounds.
Let's say.
But you will know this only when your chart bot chats with thousands of people.
And when a lot of data comes to you,
Then you will see this pattern that whenever it talks to technical background people,
It talks properly.
But when it talks to non-technical people,
Then a little bias develops in it.
So this is also something that you can only face in production.
You will not be able to face it from the beginning.
So yeah, roughly, there can be a lot of systematic failures in production
which you would not have anticipated earlier.
And third, there is a very important thing in production which we call drift.
Drift means that basically,
Your offline eval,
The testing and deployment you did with the help of which,
It starts to get obsolete.
How? I will tell you.
So let's say we made a chart bot of CampusX.
So now we have put all our documents, all pricing structure,
The course pages, curriculum pages,
Our lectures transcripts,
Put all this.
This is today's thing.
Now what are we doing over the years?
What are we doing over the years?
We are making changes.
Like we changed the price of a course.
We changed someone's curriculum.
There was a little change in our policies.
You understand right?
As the business operates, its documents also start changing gradually.
So after a year, it may be possible that the documents that we are now giving to our chart bot,
To make a rag,
They are very different compared to the documents a year ago.
But the test cases that we made, the golden dataset that we made,
It was made according to today.
What will happen after a year?
Since the whole data has changed,
Its distribution has changed,
Then our golden dataset, our whole eval pipeline,
Will become kind of obsolete.
So because of that drift,
What will happen?
That our eval pipeline is still giving us good results.
When we will test it offline, our application.
But when we will take it online,
We will see that we are getting a lot of negative feedback from our users.
Because they are not liking the chart bot's behavior.
And all this is happening because,
We are changing things,
But we are not changing our eval setup.
So the eval setup has become kind of obsolete because of the drift that is happening.
So is this point clear?
This was the most technical point among the three.
Is the point clear?
That if the drift starts occurring in some system,
Then its eval setup,
The offline eval setup,
Will become obsolete and its results will not matter.
Is this point clear?
We are right now discussing,
What kind of risks are there after deployment?
There are three types of risks.
First, the user will ask any kind of question.
There is no control over it.
Second, there can be a lot of emergent systematic failures.
Such as bias can occur.
The latency can increase when the concurrent load increases.
And third, drift can occur in the picture.
These three pointers are clear.
I understood the risks in the production setup.
Guys, the rest of you also interact a little.
Otherwise, I will not understand whether I have to explain more or stop.
Okay?
Okay. Thank you.
So basically, the discussion up to here is telling us that,
Offline eval is necessary.
Because it is necessary to test before launch.
But even after launch,
There are many types of risks in production.
And those risks cannot be covered by offline eval.
Is this statement true?
Is this statement true according to you?
That the risks in production,
We cannot solve them with the help of offline eval.
And the simple reason for that is,
What is the way to work with offline eval?
You need a golden data set.
In which you give the correct answer.
And the evaluation is done on the basis of that.
But the problem is that, once you go to production,
You don't have a golden data set.
Now the user can ask anything.
And you don't have the correct answers.
You don't even know that in the future,
When my chatbot will be deployed,
Which student will come and ask the question?
And what is the correct answer to that question?
You don't know that.
So basically, if we can conclude,
The conclusion would be that,
After testing with offline eval,
After deploying,
There are many types of risks in production setup.
And you cannot evaluate those risks,
With the help of offline eval.
We have given this statement till now.
And that is why, who comes in the picture?
Online eval.
I can understand the work from the name.
Online eval is evaluating your system,
On live production traffic,
After deployment,
As real users interact with it.
The simplest definition of online eval is,
That it is a different type of evaluation,
Which we run on production,
After our software is deployed.
And the biggest characteristic of it is,
That it works without an answer.
It works without a golden data set.
This is the biggest feature of online eval.
And that is why it is super critical,
Because it helps us,
That our software, which is deployed,
Keeps running properly.
It tells us that,
There is no problem with online.
In that sense, online evals are super important.
So, on the basis of the discussion till now,
If I quickly lay out a difference,
Between offline and online,
There are 4-5 pointers.
First of all, offline eval,
Is before deployment,
After online eval deployment.
Talking about data,
In offline eval, you have a fixed data set,
Which you create,
Golden data set.
Here, you don't have any such data set,
You are actually working on the live production traffic.
Whatever questions are being asked,
You run online eval on all those questions.
Talking about answer key,
Mostly, in offline evals,
You have an answer key.
Basically, your golden data set.
Here, you don't have any answer key.
You have to estimate,
On the go, what can be the right answer.
Talking about timing,
We have discussed that it is before deployment,
And it runs consistently after deployment.
Talking about input,
In offline eval, you only give the same things in input,
Which you anticipate.
You have created golden data set,
What all things you put in golden data set,
Which you have anticipated.
Here, you cannot anticipate what may come.
Anything can come.
Catches, offline eval generally helps in catching regression.
Here, you can catch drift,
You can catch any kind of surprise,
You can catch any kind of emergent bug,
Which we have discussed.
Offline eval is best used for gating.
Gating means,
As I told you earlier,
If your threshold,
Your score after conducting offline evaluation,
Is above the threshold,
You directly push the code with the help of CI,
Deploy it.
Version comparison, CI.
Here, the simple work of online eval is,
Drift detection,
And how your chat bot is performing in real world,
Talking about cost and speed,
Offline eval is fast, cheap and repeatable,
Because it's basically,
You are running a simple code,
Or a LLM on a small data set,
So it's cheap and fast,
Whereas in online eval,
It can be on a very large scale,
That you may have to do an evaluation,
Your chat bot is talking to 50,000 people in a day,
So you have to monitor those 50,000 people,
You have to monitor those 50,000 conversations,
So it can be costly.
So here, the sampling type technique is used,
Rather than monitoring each of the conversations,
Each of the 50,000 conversations,
You sample around,
And you are monitoring 1,000 of those conversations,
Randomly.
So you bring down the cost a little.
So these are the main differences,
Between offline and online eval.
The most important thing you have to understand here,
Is that these two are not rivals,
It's not like offline eval's replacement is online eval,
Both these things are always together,
These two are complementary,
It's not like one will be, the other will not,
It's very important to have both together.
A very good line that I read somewhere,
Is that your offline eval,
It checks if your application is working correctly or not,
This line is very important, listen carefully,
The work of offline eval is to check,
If your application is working correctly or not,
Whereas, the work of online eval is to tell,
If your application is normally running or not,
In production,
These are the two main purposes,
Offline eval will tell you,
If your application is working correctly or not,
Online will tell you,
At this point,
Your application is working correctly or not,
This is the main purpose,
So you have to check,
If your application is working correctly or not,
This is the main purpose,
So you have to check,
This will tell you,
At this point,
Your application is working normally or not,
Is this point clear?
We will go into the lecture more,
We will see how online eval works,
What are the things different from offline eval,
We will read all that in detail,
But did you understand the purpose?
Both have their own purpose,
It's not like,
You can use online in offline cases,
No, they are different.
I will give you an example of this,
The statement I said,
Offline eval tells correctness,
Online eval tells normalcy,
I will give you an example of this,
Remember our UPSC grader,
Who checks the paper,
Can you tell me,
When we were discussing in the last class,
Offline evaluation of this system,
So what were we doing exactly?
What were we trying to do?
When we were applying offline eval,
We discussed in great detail that
What are the purposes we were trying to solve?
Do you remember
In the last session,
We discussed UPSC grader,
We discussed in great detail there that
Our grader,
Now this grader that will evaluate UPSC papers, is it evaluating the same papers as a human evaluates?
This is what we were trying to do. So what was the measure of correctness here?
That the marks that this grader is giving to a particular answer should be around what the human has given.
This is what will happen, right? So with the help of this we were checking the correctness of this system.
What is the definition of correctness here? That the marks that your system is giving are close to the marks given by the human.
Now think for a while that I have evaluated this system offline, I am satisfied, I have deployed it.
Now in the online setup, when it is deployed, can I measure its correctness?
Think and tell me, can I tell you in the online setup that the answer that my software is evaluating right now,
how correct is it? Can I evaluate this? Can I evaluate correctness? Why not?
Many people are saying no, but why not? Because the answer that I am evaluating at this point,
I don't know the human marks of that answer. Basically I don't have a golden data set for this particular answer which I am evaluating right now.
There is no human perspective in production. This answer has not been evaluated by a human.
This is being evaluated directly by my system for the first time. So I cannot measure the correctness.
So you are understanding the point? We checked the correctness in the offline evaluation, then we deployed it.
But once it is deployed, we cannot check the correctness. But what can we check online that is the system running normally?
We can check this. Think and tell me, how can we figure out that at this moment the papers that are being evaluated,
the answers that are being evaluated are working normally. I am not asking that they are working correctly.
I am asking how do we know that they are working normally. It is very simple. What can you do?
You check that last week, the distribution of scores was how much?
You plot a graph that last week all the answers that we evaluated from this system,
how was the distribution of the scores? If the distribution of all the evaluations of this week is the same,
can you guarantee or say that our system is working as it was last week?
And if last week was correct, then today is also correct. You made this the baseline.
And you are always comparing the baseline in production. Suddenly you saw that in a particular week,
the distribution of your evaluations has changed a lot. So would you say that now your system is doing something different from normal,
something abnormal, which will give you a trigger and you will go and see what went wrong.
So did you understand these examples? The difference between these two words, correctness and normalcy.
I feel I gave a recent example. You tell me if you understood or not.
I guess distribution of what? Let's say I am evaluating the paper of 1000 people in a week.
First student scored 300 marks, second student scored 456 marks, third student scored 700 marks.
So I can plot these scores. So this distribution was this week's.
Then I saw the next three weeks, so I understood that this is my baseline distribution. Roughly, I get such answers.
But in a particular week, suddenly high scores started coming in the evaluations.
Around 900, 800, 700. So suddenly your distribution has changed.
So from this you understood. Yes, exactly. Now Shoaib said that distribution might be due to some other trend.
Something else can happen. Suddenly, a very intelligent student came and gave the exam.
But you know, you will go and see where the problem is. Why are we giving such high scores suddenly?
You will go and investigate it. But you are told that something evaluated it. That is online evaluation.
Online evaluation cannot guarantee correctness. It can do in some cases. It doesn't do in some cases.
So it mostly tells you that your application is working normally or not. That is the purpose of online evaluation.
Is this point clear? Look, don't sit holding the example. I have constructed an example just to explain the difference.
Now it is not that this example is applicable everywhere. I just wanted to explain to you what correctness means and what normal means.
Is the point clear? We have just discussed the difference between online evaluation and offline evaluation.
And we have discussed what is the purpose of both of them. Is this clear till now? Is it making sense?
You have to tell me that do you feel in your life that online evaluation is important and work will not be possible without it?
If you are feeling this much, then the lecture is going well till now. It means you have understood.
If you feel that online evaluation is not necessary, then there is a problem in understanding or in my teaching method.
Ok, so I will take a small break. At this point, if you have any questions based on the discussion that we are having, tell me.
Shiv is asking, but online Eval has no answer. How we actually estimate quality?
There are many ways. You will understand it now. I will give an example.
For example, the Rack chart is a chatbot. You can find many things in the Rack chart. You can see how faithfulness is.
You don't need to know the right answer to check the faithfulness. Faithfulness means whether the answer has been generated from the context of the retrieval.
You have the context and the answer. You can ask an LLM that the answer has been generated from the context.
You can find out the faithfulness. In many cases, you can give the correct answer without knowing the correct answer.
In some scenarios, if you don't have the correct answer, then you have to put a juggad.
For example, in the example of UPSC, you don't have the correct answer. So what juggad did you put here?
You compared it with the baseline distribution and see whether your system is working normally or not.
Either you have a metric that you don't need to know the right answer to. Like faithfulness.
Or if you have a metric that you need to know the correct answer to. In that case, you are restricted.
You will have to think about how to come to a conclusion. I will give another example.
One example is that you want to measure the correctness of your chatbot in the online setup.
So think about it and tell me, can the correctness of the chatbot be measured in the online setup?
I am talking about correctness. Is the answer giving the correct answer or not?
Can we measure correctness in the online setup after deployment?
If I don't have the correct answer to any new question, then I can't evaluate it.
So how can I find out that my chatbot is making a mistake?
Think about it and tell me. I don't have the correct answer because the user can ask any question. I don't have the answer.
So how can we find out the correctness that my chatbot is giving the correct answer at this point or in the last one hour or not?
Is there any other signal that can tell this instead of the correct answer?
Let me tell you. What if you have given the option of thumbs up and thumbs down in your chatbot?
If you suddenly start seeing that in the last one hour, the rating of thumbs down is coming in a lot of conversations,
then what will you understand from this? That something or the other has gone wrong.
Something or the other is giving the wrong answer to our chatbot.
So again, this is a tricky way to find out that is the correctness working properly or not?
Yes, basically the user's feedback has been done.
So here the correctness has been alternated by the user's feedback.
Yeah Aman, we judge LLM as a judge. I will show you now.
Look, understand one thing. One important thing is that the questions you are asking are a little ahead of the questions.
Because we have not discussed the how part of online evals yet.
Technically, we just discussed that why do we need online evals and what exactly are online evals?
But how does it work? I have not told you yet.
So that is why the questions that are coming to you are a little ahead of the questions.
Trust me, the next topic that we will discuss now, things will be clear to you from there.
The questions that are coming to your mind will be closed.
If there is any question in why and what of online evals, then tell me.
Why and what? Why do we need online evals and what are online evals?
If there is any question in both of these, then you can ask.
What are the general metrics and signals tracked via online evaluation?
Look, again, this is also a question that we will discuss now.
Look, just the one that is written on the screen in front of you.
Now I am going to discuss that what kind of signals you work on online, what you see, where can there be a problem.
We will discuss that now. So don't worry, we are going to discuss all this.
If you have any other question, ask.
Okay.
Shruti Singh, I didn't get the distribution part.
Shruti, it was very simple. What did I explain?
That I have no way in production to find out that at this moment, the system that is evaluating the paper,
is it evaluating it correctly or not? Why?
Because I have the answer to the current paper, as in the answer is there,
but the user, as in the human, has given him so many marks, I don't have this.
Right? So I can't compare that how much the human gave, how much I gave, so did I do it right or not?
Right? This is the problem.
So how can I evaluate that the evaluations that I am doing at this moment or the evaluations that I am doing today,
or the evaluations that I am doing today, is it correct or not?
So what we found out is that what we do is that we, after evaluating every score,
the total score that comes after evaluating every paper, we store it somewhere.
And then we plot it in the window of one week.
Okay?
So basically, a graph of a distribution will be made.
This is from 0 to 1000.
So what this distribution is telling is that most of the children's marks have come around 500.
Many children's marks have come around 700 and very few children's marks have come around 200.
This is about last week.
Okay?
Now let's talk about week 2.
What we saw in week 2 is that suddenly when we plotted the same graph that how many marks each child has got,
then that graph started looking like this.
Basically, this means that the most marks of the children's marks came around 800.
And very few children's marks came around 200, 300, or 500.
So after seeing these two graphs, can you conclude that last week is different in comparison to this week?
The last week, the papers that we evaluated, the results that came after evaluating the papers,
that is very different to this week.
And before this, this distribution was being made in every week.
In week 1, it was being made like this, in week 2, it was being made like this, in week 3, it was being made like this,
in week 4, it was being made like this, in week 5, it was being made like this.
So these distributions, by comparing week by week, you will understand that something is different this week,
something is wrong, why suddenly my software started giving more marks.
This is the point.
So what we did was that we didn't have any way to measure correctness,
so we started comparing from the last baseline.
From that we understood that our software is working normally or not.
That's the point.
I hope you understood now.
Okay.
So now, the most important section of this class,
in which you are going to read the most important things.
We are going to see how an online evaluation pipeline looks.
Okay.
Look, the first step in an online evaluation pipeline is very important.
The first step is very important.
And that step is called logging.
So the basic idea is this, that your chat bot is live on production and people are talking to it.
Now, if you want to evaluate anything, then the most important thing for that is that
you first record all the things that are happening right now, all the conversations that are happening right now.
Obviously, if you don't record it, then it will be lost.
And if it is lost, then what will you evaluate?
So the first step is logging.
Look, I have written it here.
The idea behind logging is simple.
You capture a structured replayable record of every conversation done.
So if I have deployed the campus chat bot on the website and if I am getting 50,000 conversations done with my chat bot all day,
then what will I do?
I will store these 50,000 conversations properly somewhere.
Now, what is the meaning of storing the conversation?
What things will I store?
First of all, I will give a conversation ID to every conversation.
I will give a turn ID to every turn that is happening in it.
I will give a user ID to the user who is doing the conversation.
I will give a session ID to the user.
I will give a timestamp to the time at which the conversation is happening.
I will store all this information.
Then I will store the question that the user asked.
What context was generated in the rag chat bot in the process of answering that question?
I will store that context in the chat bot.
I will store the output that the chat bot gave on the basis of that context and question.
Apart from that, I will store a lot of operational things such as latency in milliseconds,
how many tokens were spent in the prompt, how many completion tokens are there,
how much total cost was spent, did any error come?
If an error came, what is its status code?
I will store all this.
Apart from this, if the user is giving me some other signals, I will store those signals too.
Like if there is a behavioral metric such as he is pressing thumbs up or thumbs down
during the conversation, then I will store that too.
Is he mailing?
He is saying that I don't want to talk to you, I want to talk to a human or give my email ID,
I want to mail.
So if the matter is escalating, I will store that.
The user is asking the same questions again and again because he feels that the chat bot is not helping him,
he is rephrasing the question.
So I will store all these things.
Everything will be stored.
Can someone tell me a tool to store all this?
Have you seen a tool in the past where you use that tool to store such things?
Perfect. Amin was right.
I had also taught on YouTube, we had covered in detail that we had made a chat bot
and we were storing every conversation of that chat bot.
Where? On Langsmith. I can show you right now.
So see this.
This is Langsmith.
Langsmith has different projects.
What can you do in those projects?
All your conversations are there.
These are all conversations.
You can store those conversations.
You store everything in it.
What the user sent, what was your output,
there is a lot of metadata.
Everything is stored.
So this is kept with you.
Now this storage, this whole logging,
it has some engineering properties.
You should know this.
First of all, this logging should be non-blocking.
Non-blocking means that you are logging everything.
So this logging is also an operation.
So you have to run the chat bot and also log.
So these two shouldn't be like this that in each other,
they are basically,
by doing both together, the latency shouldn't increase.
So it should be non-blocking.
Means, on one side your conversation is going on normally
and on the other side your logging is also going on.
So it should be non-blocking.
Basically, you should not increase the latency by combining both the operations.
Second, the logging should be durable and curable.
Queryable.
Basically, you use a data warehouse type tool
or an observability tool such as Langsmith.
Where you can store all this information in a very structured way.
And the best part is that you can fetch it back anytime in the future.
This is very important.
Third, you should also do late signal attachments.
Late signal attachment means that many times,
many user's signals don't come immediately when the conversation is going on.
They come later.
For example,
suppose the user has escalated.
He mailed.
Conversation happened, he didn't benefit.
He went and mailed the next day on support-at-the-rate.campus-x.in.
So this escalation happened after one day of conversation.
But we also have to record this.
That escalation happened.
How will we record this?
We have a conversation ID.
We have to figure out from that conversation ID
that the escalation happened from that conversation ID.
So you have to track all this.
Basically, you have to store any late signals.
And lastly, PII handling.
Basically, if during your conversation,
if the user has shared his personal sensitive information with you,
with chatbot, phone number, address or card number,
then what will you do?
Before storing it in Langsmith,
you will remove it or blur it or somehow spoil it.
So that in the future,
any of your teammates or employee can't extract that information from Langsmith.
So privacy should be maintained.
So this is your...
Yes, masking is also done.
Actually, it should be masking only because it is textual information.
So it will be masking.
So yeah, this is the first act.
Logging.
Did you understand the logging?
Why do you have to do it?
How do you have to do it?
We have just discussed both the things.
Did you understand?
PII means personal identifiable information.
Phone number, card number, date of birth, Aadhaar number.
If you have shared anything like this with chatbot,
then we will mask it and store it in Langsmith.
Whatever it is,
we are discussing how to make an online eval pipeline.
So the first step is that
before evaluating anything,
you have to store everything first.
Okay?
You have to log somewhere.
Generally, it is some data warehouse
or some observability tool like Langsmith.
Is there any problem in step 1?
Is step 1 clear?
Did you understand the logging problem?
Okay.
Now comes step 2.
Now before discussing step 2,
we have to find out
what matters in online evaluation.
What kind of signals do you have to pay attention to?
What things will you understand
that whether your chatbot is working properly or not?
Okay?
So there are actually two types of signals
which you have to focus on.
The first one is computed
and the second one is captured signals.
Okay?
So computed signals are those
that you have to calculate
or figure out.
And captured signals are those
that are already present
and you have to store them somewhere.
I will give you both the examples.
For example, captured signal is
thumbs up, thumbs down.
If the user did thumbs up or thumbs down during the conversation,
then this is a signal that the user is giving me.
So I am directly storing it in the langsmith.
Now I didn't need to calculate anything here.
The user said thumbs down, I have to store it as it is.
So we call this captured signal.
One more example is latency.
To do any particular answer,
how much time did my chatbot take?
Whatever time it took, I have to store it in the langsmith.
Now I don't need to calculate anything here.
Cost per conversation.
How much token did I spend?
How much money did I spend?
Again, it is something that I don't need to calculate.
It is told by my LLM provider.
We calculate this beforehand.
We don't have to do a real-time calculation for that.
Token usage, simply counting.
We don't need to do that.
So these are the examples or signals
that you only capture and store in the langsmith.
You don't need to calculate anything in this.
Now let's talk about the computed one.
The computed one is the signal that you have to calculate.
You have to figure out.
For example, you want to see in the online production setup
how much is the faithfulness of your chatbot.
Now this is something that you won't get only by storing the chat.
You will have to make an evaluator for this.
An online evaluator.
You will send that chat to this online evaluator.
This online evaluator will calculate and compute
how much is the faithfulness score.
So this is an example of a quantity or metric or signal
that we have to calculate.
You have to compute answer relevance, correctness, hallucination, toxicity,
bias and fairness.
You have to compute all these things.
So is this point clear?
First of all, see what kind of signals we are giving importance to
in the production setup.
There are two categories.
One that we have to compute and the other that we simply capture and store.
Okay?
Just see this once.
Everything is very simple and straightforward.
This is all chatbot related.
And these are your general quantities
which are probably in normal software as well.
LLM based software is not special.
This is also in normal software.
Is this point clear?
Okay.
So basically, how does online eval pipeline look like?
First of all, we have stored the conversation on the landsmith.
Okay?
Now, if we talk about a captured quantity,
like latency,
we don't have to calculate anything here.
So we go straight to the next step,
which is
dashboarding.
So what happens is that in every production setup,
you create a dashboard.
And in that dashboard, you show these quantities.
And how do you show them?
On a time basis.
How is the latency in the last one hour?
How is the latency in the last 24 hours?
How is the latency in the last one week?
How is the latency in the last six months?
Right?
So if you are observing a quantity
which is a captured quantity,
and you don't want to compute anything,
there is no need to compute anything,
you send it directly to your dashboard.
And in that dashboard, you can see its graph.
And from that graph, you can understand
whether your system is working normally or not.
For example, suddenly you launched a course.
I launched a course.
50,000 people came to the website together.
They started charting from the chart board.
And now you can see that suddenly
the time to reply to your chart board has increased.
The latency has increased.
So your graph was going like this till now.
Suddenly it will look like this.
So looking at this graph, you will understand
that something is wrong.
So what will you do immediately?
You will allocate more resources.
Let's say you are on AWS.
So you will start more EC2 instances.
You will start your load balancer and so on.
And then you will manage the traffic in some way.
So after some time, automatically your latency will come down again.
So is this point clear?
Did you understand this pipeline?
This pipeline for a captured quantity.
Logged.
You sent that log directly to your dashboard.
And the dashboard is showing you this graph
through which you can understand what is going on.
Now there is an important component in dashboarding.
Its next stage is alerting.
You will not keep looking at the graph all day.
Right. If you have an engineer, he will not keep looking at the graph for 24 hours.
It may be on leave or sleeping or anything.
So what you do is you set up alerts.
Basically if a threshold is crossed by our quantity,
then you create an alert.
Let's say on Slack or on email or WhatsApp.
WhatsApp is generally not done.
But let's say on WhatsApp.
As soon as you cross this quantity,
your concerned team engineer gets an alert mail.
That the latency is more than 4 milliseconds.
So he will quickly normalize things.
So this is the flow for captured quantities.
Logging, dashboarding, alerting.
Here I write, if you are talking about a captured quantity,
the flow is like this.
You log, you present it on a dashboard,
and you set up an alert system.
This is the flow.
This is not the flow for computed quantities.
We will discuss that now.
In fact, I will show you now.
You will find it interesting.
If you see here in Langsmith,
you will see monitoring.
If you click on monitoring,
then whatever your project is,
you can select your project from here.
For that project, you will see that
many types of,
basically a dashboard is already made.
In that dashboard, your graphs are made.
Look at this.
Trace latency, error rate,
LLM call count, LLM latency,
different graphs of cost.
All these are made.
See.
So this will help me understand
how is the health of my system.
Here, the interesting thing is,
see what I was saying.
You can select from here.
Last 1 hour, 3 hours, 6 hours.
So you can aggregate these quantities
and see.
The latency in the current chat
is not different from that.
In the last one hour,
the overall latency, the aggregated latency,
is meaningful for me.
So whenever you are dashboarding,
then for you,
one single conversation
in isolation does not matter.
In one single conversation,
it is possible that the latency
goes up and down.
But if in the last one hour,
the latency is increasing
in many conversations,
it means your average latency
is going up for the last one hour,
it shows that something is wrong in the system.
The system level is wrong.
So that is what you see here.
So here, you can see all these
in different categories.
Here, see, there is a system called
alerts.
From here, you can make new alerts.
You can select a project.
You can name an alert.
You can select the metric
on which you want to make an alert.
After that, it is said that
alert when feedback metric,
you will select a metric from here.
It is more than this in the last 5 minutes
or whatever.
So it is a platform on Slack
or PagerDuty,
Dynatrash,
or you can connect your own API
here so that you can do
the alerting as per your needs.
Dashboarding and alerting.
So we discussed this flow
for any captured quantity
which does not have any computation.
There is no need to set up an evaluator.
We directly recorded a quantity.
Where did we record it?
Here. We recorded it in tracing.
See, here is tracing.
We recorded it in tracing
that this is the latency,
2.03 seconds, 2.03 seconds.
And we are showing this in monitoring.
And in the last one hour,
if it suddenly increases,
then we have set up an alert system
for it.
So that I get to know and then I can take
some necessary actions according to it.
So is this flow clear for
a captured quantity?
For this kind of quantity?
We discussed for this.
Just one second.
What happened?
For these quantities.
Is it still clear?
We are getting some perspective
on how things are working in production.
It looks a little interesting.
Okay.
So I will again
take a small break.
If you have any questions
at this point of time,
whatever we have read,
you can ask.
You can ask.
Yes, sure.
Computed and captured logins
work together.
As I said, you make multiple
pipelines.
So we are discussing
captured eval pipelines.
This is not exactly a pipeline,
to be honest. There is no pipeline here.
There are a series of steps.
You will see a pipeline in the computed one
because you will have to set up an evaluator there.
So you will understand from that.
Is there any other question
at this point?
Okay.
So now let's discuss
the main part,
the most interesting part.
When you have to
track a computed
quantity
in production.
Let's take an example.
Let's say
there is an example
of a pipeline
that is not in production.
Let's say the example is
Let me think.
Let's say the example is hallucination.
Okay.
We have to see
in real time
that is our chatbot
hallucinating or not?
We have to test this
in production. Okay.
So how will this work?
So look at this too.
The pipeline looks like this.
The pipeline is like this.
Here also you log in first.
So if you are
carrying out 50,000 conversations
in a day, your chatbot is doing 50,000
conversations, then you will
actually log
each of the conversations
using a tool like LangSmith.
Okay.
After that, in step 2
what you have to do is
you have to set up an evaluator.
You have to create an evaluator.
Okay.
Now this evaluator is
a reference
free evaluator.
Does anyone remember from the last class
what is the difference between reference based
and reference free evaluations?
Do you know?
Do you remember?
I told you.
If you are performing an evaluation
where you have an answer key
in your golden
data set, then what is that
evaluation called?
Reference based.
The example of which was
UPSC.
If we are carrying out an evaluation
where we don't have
a golden data set and no
answer key, then
what do we call this kind of evaluation?
Reference free evaluation.
Right?
So what we have to do now is
we have to get the hallucination rate.
That is, is our chatbot
hallucinating or not?
On any given question.
So quickly think about it and tell me
that do I have
a golden data set? Do I have an answer key?
The user asked me a question
and my chatbot gave me an answer.
Do I have an answer key?
The answer given by the user
is hallucination or not?
Is there a golden data set? Is there a correct answer key?
No, it's not.
I don't have it.
So this is a reference free evaluation.
But I have to do the evaluation.
Right? I have to do the evaluation.
So
for this, what I will do is
I will simply use
a LLM
as a judge.
I will simply
bring a more powerful LLM
and
I will show it
in a retrieved context.
I will show
the question the user asked.
And the output
my LLM generated, I will show that.
And I will say
that tell me
is the LLM hallucinating
or not? Basically, I will
write a detailed rubric
and give it to the user.
Which will guide
this LLM as a judge
that at some particular place
our original LLM
is hallucinating or not?
Right?
But here is a problem.
A very big problem.
Think and tell me, this evaluator
that we have made where we are using
this LLM as a judge and giving it this rubric
can we
apply it on
50,000 conversations or not?
This is the question.
If my chatbot is doing 50,000
conversations a day
and I have to check the hallucination
that whether it hallucinates
or not?
And for that I have created an evaluator.
The evaluator is an LLM itself.
So should I
leave this LLM as a judge
on 50,000 conversations?
Obviously, no.
It will be very very costly.
First, you have to pay to run
your chatbot.
You are paying for the 50,000 conversations
that you are doing.
Now if you pay to evaluate it
then the cost can be double.
So here in between
there is a step
where you do
sampling.
Basically, in 50,000
conversations a day
you randomly select
1000 conversations
randomly.
And on those
1000 conversations
you run your evaluator
which is
an LLM as a judge.
And then this evaluator
gives you a quantity
hallucination rate
and that
quantity you pick up
and send it
to your dashboard.
Like we sent the quantities above.
And then from this dashboard
you create alerts.
So basically
the flow is exactly the same as above.
What is additional
is that you have to do sampling
because obviously you have to save cost.
And in between there is an additional
step of evaluation where you are
computing the value.
Hallucination rate. And then the next
step is exactly the same.
Don't worry, I will show you practically
how it works.
Now here you can ask one more question
or I will tell you.
If you
think about it
if you randomly
select 1000
out of 50,000 conversations
randomly
then this random sampling
is it a good strategy
or can be a better strategy than this?
50,000 conversations are happening
I randomly selected 1000
and I am checking
if there is hallucination
in those 1000.
Is this the best strategy around
or can I use a better strategy
than this?
My simple question is
should I do random sampling
or something else?
Yes, like Amar
said that we can
ignore those conversations where we
got thumbs up.
It is valid right? Where the student gave
the thumbs up. Most likely
he is happy with the chatbot
performance so there must not be hallucination.
Most likely we can assume that.
It is not exactly a fact but
it is a good signal.
What is the use of keeping those conversations?
We will not know that.
What about
we focus more on those questions
where we got thumbs down?
Will it be a good strategy?
Think about it.
Will it be a good strategy
if we focus more on those questions
where we got thumbs down?
Right?
Or we focus on
those conversations
which suddenly got over
abruptly or where
escalations happened.
Or where
I don't know
the user is rephrasing the same question
in different ways.
Or where
we are talking about
money, refund,
admission, fees.
So basically what I am trying
to say is that not all
conversations are the same.
What you do is
you do stratified
sampling.
Stratified sampling.
You
basically
divide all your conversations
into categories.
And then you
pick up more samples
in problematic categories.
Like
we are talking about money or thumbs down.
So I will pick up
more samples from those categories
and less samples from normal ones.
So from this
the sampled conversations
I will get, there is
more chance of
hallucination being detected.
So I have discussed
the same thing with you.
We are doing clustering.
You will have to set a small model for this.
A small model will detect
which one has thumbs down, which one
is talking like this.
So this is technicality.
I just wanted to tell you that
you don't do normal sampling
you do stratified sampling.
So is the point
clear guys?
So far the flow I have told you is correct.
We have locked it.
After that we did sampling.
After that we set up
our evaluator.
Evaluator performs the evaluation
on those sampled conversations
and gives us the metric.
We are aggregating that metric
over a time period and showing it
on the dashboard. And if a threshold
is crossing then I am
triggering the alerting system.
This is the entire flow for
online eval.
There is one evaluation pipeline.
You set up multiple evaluators
and multiple eval pipelines.
In fact I will show you how this whole thing happens.
Let me show it to you
using Langsmith. See.
See here. Can you see
here there is an option
called evaluators?
See.
Here get started with evaluators
is one. Go to show all templates.
From here
you can actually go through
many options.
Like there are different evaluators
for security.
And see it is written next to each one.
LLM as a judge. LLM as a judge.
It means that now this one
what is its function?
PII leakage. It computes
and tells us
that our chat bot is not
leaking any kind of personal information.
And how does this evaluator work?
Behind the scenes LLM as a judge is
sitting. Prompt injection
is different for detecting. Code injection
is different for detecting. In safety
it is different for toxicity. It is different for
bias and fairness. Talking about quality
hallucination has a different evaluation
pipeline.
Correctness is different. Assertions, conciseness
code checker.
The quality of conversation is different.
Trajectory
is actually for agent.
It is not for chat bots.
It is for agents.
It is different for image based chat bots.
It is different for voice based chat bots.
If you click on a particular one. Like we were talking about hallucination.
If you want to set up
a pipeline for hallucination then you click on it.
Here you will give it a name.
From here you will select
the application on which you want to run
this evaluation. Obviously
there can be more than one
applications in your organization.
Assume there is also one application here.
After that you will select from here that here
which model you want to use in LLM as a judge.
From here you will select
open AI or Claude or whatever.
Here you will
provide your API key
and whatever settings you want to keep
like temperature key and all these
you will set here.
After that here
you will have a prompt
which you will give to your LLM as a judge.
Here you can define your rubric.
With which you will tell how to
detect hallucination.
Here you will write some instructions of your site.
Some reminders
and some context.
We will learn all this later.
I am just showing you.
After that from here
you will tell it in which format
you want to tell the answer.
Then if you look here
then here
you have two options.
You will tell that this evaluator
which you are creating
for hallucination
you want to run it on tracing
or on data set.
Anyone can tell.
I will be very impressed if you can answer this.
If I run this evaluator
on tracing
then what does it mean?
Can anyone tell?
This is an interesting question actually.
Here I am getting two settings
that I am making this evaluator
I can run it on tracing.
Tracing means
whatever we are tracing and logging
If I run it on tracing
or logging then what will happen?
And if I run it on a data set
then what will happen? This is the question.
This is a simple observation based.
Yes, perfect.
You have got it right.
If you run it on tracing or logging
then this evaluator
will become an online evaluator.
And if you run it on a data set
then where are the data sets?
They are in the offline setup
then it will become an offline evaluator.
So Lansmith is an overall
evaluation platform. Here you can
do online evaluation and offline as well.
So if you select one in tracing
then it will become an online evaluator.
And if I have made a data set here
then you can also make data sets here.
Go to data sets and experiments
here you can actually
create a new data set.
Now you can add your examples here
and you can create your own data set.
You select the same data set here.
We were doing the hallucination one.
So from here
go to data set
and if you select this data set
then it will become
an offline evaluator.
And if you from here
it is done, you will have to cancel it.
But you get the idea.
By selecting tracing, online evaluation is done
and by selecting data set
offline evaluation is done.
In fact I can show you how offline
is done here.
If you go to data sets and experiments
and for a while
if I delete it
I don't have
any data set
here
you can see two options.
Create a data set
with which you can create a data set and
run an experiment. If you click on new experiment
then here
you have the code
with which you can conduct offline
experiments. We will do this in the next sessions
but LangSmith
gives you the full setup. Here you can create
your data sets,
run your offline experiments
you can log in
you can monitor
you can alert
and obviously you can run
online and offline evaluators.
This is the complete
evaluation platform
LangSmith.
So this point is clear.
The entire flow is clear.
Is the entire flow clear?
Let me know.
See we are not doing it
because this is an overview class.
I am just giving you an overview
of things. That's why we are not doing
everything in this class. But you
must be getting an idea of what is happening there.
Now here is an interesting
thing. You must be remembering
when I taught you in the first class
that in production where
there are problems, in the cases, in the conversations
where there are problems, what do you do
by picking them up? You make
a part of your data set. Did you read this?
Do you remember? I told you
this. If I remember
correctly.
In the last one
see this
this flow
was the offline one.
But in the offline one, the deploy and monitor
one, there
we wrote that if there is a failure in production
then where do we put it
by picking it up?
In our offline data set.
So we do this work here also.
See here. Suppose
you are tracing and
in a particular
conversation something is wrong.
Okay. You have identified
your team.
So here you have an option
called add to data set.
By clicking on this you
can make that particular conversation
part of your offline data set.
Next time when you do
offline evaluation, you will do it on
updated data set.
This is how you close the offline
online. Along with that, in sync
you keep working.
Okay.
Here you have an option to annotate.
Here you have an option.
You can add a particular conversation
in an annotation queue.
And you can
tell what happened in that conversation.
Basically you annotate
the data that is coming online
and keep making your offline data part.
So basically it becomes a circle.
Offline evaluation happened.
Went to production.
There were failures in production.
We picked it up and added it back to the offline data set.
Again we ran offline evaluations.
We ran it, deployed it.
New failures came. The work is going on in the circle.
So this is how this entire thing works.
Is it clear?
I will come back
to the slide. This is the self
improving loop.
I was talking about this.
That you keep putting online failures
in the offline data set and if the offline data set
part is made, then the offline evaluation part is made.
Is this clear?
Ok.
So yeah guys.
That's all I wanted to teach you today.
I just wanted to give you an overall
idea about online evaluation.
I haven't done anything.
I haven't shown anything practically.
I just gave you an overview of why it happens, how it happens.
What is the flow of things.
I just told you that.
It was a beginner level class.
So I didn't have a plan to teach more than this.
Let me know
if you have any questions.
Like one or two questions are coming.
Suppose a dashboard
faithfulness is 0.87
toxicity is 0.002
latency is 3.
Is the bot
good? I want to know how we judge
by evaluating the dashboard.
Shiv actually has a baseline
of everything.
And that baseline generally comes from
offline evaluation.
So you
compare against that baseline.
Suppose your baseline, like you gave an example
faithfulness is 0.87
and your baseline is 0.85
So 0.87
is better than 0.85
so you will be happy. But suddenly
in the last 24 hours
faithfulness score went to 0.75
So against the 0.85
baseline, this
is concerning.
So you will be alerted
or you will make some improvements in the system.
That happens.
Is the
answer clear?
So guys
some
feedback, did you understand, did you enjoy it?
Did you find it interesting?
Or did you
waste your time?
We are getting some perspective.
Do you remember
before starting this course
I told you one thing
that when you complete this course
you will not just
think that I want to make a chatbot
I want to make a rag chatbot
you will sleep with an API key
your level will be up
your mindset will change
and you will start thinking that my chatbot
will work
for thousands, lakhs, crores of people
So is that picture
in your mind?
Are you sensing that mindset shift?
That I have not just made it
I am learning to run it properly
That's the idea of this playlist
and I told you that
this will separate you from your competition
because many people are not reading it
so if you learn this
then you will have value
whenever you will be in an interview
or present yourself
So we are just starting
this is technically the second lecture
but
do you feel that
there is potential in this?
Ok
So whatever we have learned in these 2-3 sessions
we will learn to apply that
golden data set
we will learn how to make it
we will learn how to run
offline evals
online evals
and along the way we will learn
some interesting tools and libraries
You have seen Langsmith
we will use Langsmith
then you will use
DeepEval library
Raga library
so that's the idea
Now the next thing we are going to read
is
benchmarks
which we have discussed
that there are 2 types of LLMEval
model level, application level
once we
take 1-2 sessions
and read model level evals
benchmarks etc
and then we will move to application eval
so that's the plan
Today is 8th
my goal will be
to complete this month's playlist
ok
it can be plus or minus 1 week
so
ask any questions guys
Sir
sorry question not related to this
lecture but can you please confirm about
loop engineering lecture this Saturday as mentioned in the
feedback call
yes Avinash
let's do
a loop engineering lecture
Friday
the old schedule is still going on
new schedule will change
from next week
so most likely
there is a 90% chance
in the next session
rather than teaching you
LLMEval I will teach you loop engineering
because many people are asking
any other question guys
ok
Sir one more question if we increase from
90 to 19 offline is it a good
92 to 99 offline is it good for
online production
see
it depends on the shift
question is not complete
92 to 99
what quantity
are we talking about
and it's not like
92 to 99
other quantities
are down
everything is improving
if something is improving
obviously it's a good thing
but in one improvement
nothing should be down
because this happens in LLME based systems
one thing is improved and
other things are down
that should not happen
Hello sir any thoughts on
how to do evals for
agentic STLC development using
Claude or other such IDEs
software
evaluation is straight forward
that
software testing
will take
correct me if I am wrong
there
is not that tricky business
simply you have to check for correctness
run test cases
if it passed then it's ok if not then it's wrong
and Claude
can do a lot of things
infact there are many
code review tools
code testing tools
for code review there is code rabbit
for testing
there is a platform called test
right which is
compatible with Claude
this company
approached us
what do you call it
to make a
sponsored video
this is
agentic testing for AI native teams
with Claude
with codex with all
but software testing is not my
expertise
I don't know that but such tools
exist if you can understand
then you can do agentic
software testing
I am not really sure if I could answer
your question correctly or not or you were
asking something else if you were asking something else
then ask
sir are we learning
landfuse as well in this playlist
not really sure
we can teach it also
my focus is not on tools
you might have seen it till now
we are focusing on concepts till now
I have shown tools as an example
but
tools are not specific
if tomorrow a new tool comes
then we will not teach new tool
you have to explain basics fundamentals
someone has raised their hand
I guess you want to ask
something
you can ask
sir I have a small doubt
like you were asking
we are taking 10,000 samples randomly
so
we said 1000
so we took 1000 from that
but randomly
but my question is since we are
checking time series
weekly, bi-weekly
can we set an evaluation
where we can capture
20% of my total conversation
trend
because we have to capture drift as well
is it good to take the last 10,000
conversation
like 20% of 50,000
to make sure that
the most relevant trend
is captured instead of random sampling
is it worth it in this scenario
no no no
see what we said
chatbot is doing 50,000 conversations
in a day
right
this is what we were talking about
every day 50,000 conversations
now you are saying
at any moment I will take
last 10,000 conversations
this is what you are saying
which basically be like
you took all the conversations
in the last 5 hours
this is what it means
so
means
now
no I don't think
I think
you have to decide this first of all
it will depend on your application
how fast you have to
compute all this
what finance related apps
so time matters a lot
half an hour or an hour matters a lot
in education apps
I think the last 24 hours evaluation period is also good
so now in the last 24 hours
I have
randomly
or stratified sampling
and took out 1000 conversations
so it serves my purpose
but if I only take out
the last 1000 conversations
then it doesn't capture
my overall distribution
basically
means
it does not make sense to me
means if you feel
you tell me
what is your thought process
I have unmuted you
actually
second question
is
let's say I am not doing it on birthday
but if I do it bi-weekly
because I have found out
that according to my use case
let's say my bi-weekly trend is changing
let's say I am working in a dynamic environment
so my question
is
is it good to take rolling conversations
is a good strategy for specific use cases
not on a daily basis
but can this be used
this is my question
because rather than randomly taking rolling
if I take it at the last
are there any use cases where it can be useful
or is it completely like
generally we don't use it in such setups
that is what I want to know
I haven't studied honestly
all the systems I have studied
I have never seen this
that at any point
to perform the evaluation I am taking the last
n conversations this is what you are saying
I am trying to think
what case can be where
I simply take the last n conversations
and my work will be done
I am not able to
figure out a scenario
give me time
I will research on my level
one more question
this is a bit basic
generally we say that
over time data drift
but if I am a system
where my input dynamics are not changing
let's say I have
sampled 100 documents
and my work is just
to query on it
in this setup do you still think
that after a while the data will drift
and the data will not change
or we have not given
the user the freedom to
pull the data
drift has many natures
you are talking about data drift
you have controlled data drift
because you haven't changed anything
model can also drift
in fact your user
can also drift
I am giving a very bad example
let's say suddenly
millennials used your platform
and suddenly
gen z's started using
so from the expectation point of view
there is a drift
that what is he expecting, he is not getting the answer
he is giving thumbs down
now your current offline evaluation
everything is working fine
but your user
who was a millennial before
is not happy with it
so that is also a drift
which you have to see
I don't know
I haven't given a good example
drift can be of many types
we were talking about data drift
but model drift
and I am trying to think
what other types of drift can be
concept drift
what I have discussed is concept drift
that
expectation mismatch
concept has changed
that chart board was used for some other purpose
and now it is used for some other purpose
so you can drift from any type
so drift you cannot control
I don't think
you can control drift in any AI based system
some form of drift
gets in
any other question guys
if there is no other question
we can close the session
I will wait for 2-3 minutes
if there is no other question
I will close the session
can overlap last 1000
if we check
monday and
wednesday
yes yes
in rolling it will overlap
it depends on
how much window
duration you have
so overlapping happens
that is called
window concept
that is why your window is sliding
ok guys if there is no other question
see you in next class
ok bye good night